تهانينا يا سيدي ، ساعدنا في
فهم البيانات إذا كنت ستحصل من ناحية على
اللقاح
90 فعالية عند إعطائه نصف جرعة
متبوعة بجرعة كاملة على الأقل شهرًا
على الأخرى
عند إعطائك كجرعتين كاملتين أه لدينا
بعض  62 الفعالية ،
أنا لست جيدًا في هذه الأشياء ، لذا ساعدنا في
معرفة ما تخبرنا به اليوم
أننا نخبرنا بأننا نخبرك
أننا اختبرنا نظامي تحصين مختلفين
أحدهما هو النظام القياسي حيث
تعطي نفس الجرعة مرتين
والآخر  نوع جديد إلى حد ما من
النظام الغذائي حيث يمكنك زيادة الجرعة ، لذلك
بدأنا بنصف جرعة
ثم التطعيم الثاني كان
مع المجلدات
ومن المثير للاهتمام أنه أعطى فعالية عالية جدًا
من 90 كانت ذات دلالة إحصائية عالية
لذا تبدو هذه
نتيجة حقيقية لـ  عالية الكفاءة
ولا نفهم ذلك تمامًا ولكن
هناك العديد من الأفكار حول
كيفية عملها وأه نحن نستكشفها ،
لذا كم من الوقت سيستغرقك
لفهم ما  تجري
هنا ،
ربما أسابيع وشهور للقيام بذلك ،
نحن بالطبع ننظر إلى ذلك في
تجارب أخرى كما تعلمون ، هناك تجربة كبيرة جدًا
قيد التشغيل في الولايات المتحدة
الآن تم تجنيد حوالي 10000 شخص
بالفعل وستكون الأرقام  بين 30
و 40000 بحلول الوقت الذي ننتهي فيه ،
لذلك
قد تتاح لنا الفرصة
لإعادة تقييم هذا في الولايات المتحدة.
هو الذي يتم
توزيعه ، نعم ، إنه نفس
اللقاح الذي سيتم توزيعه
وعادة ما تأتي اللقاحات في عشرة من هذه الملفات ،
لذا فهو حقًا اختيار
المستخدم النهائي سواء كنت تعطي نظامًا واحدًا
أو آخر لأنه من
السهل جدًا إعطاء النصف  جرعة
وقد ناقشنا هذا الأمر مع
وزارة الصحة في المملكة المتحدة ،
فهم واثقون جدًا من أن ذلك
سيكون واضحًا ومباشرًا ،
لذا لا يمثل ذلك تحديًا لوجستيًا
وبالطبع لا يزال هناك القليل من المال.
o قد تكون على دراية بأن أسترازينيكا
قد أبرمت عقودًا لتصنيع
ما يصل إلى 3 مليارات جرعة من هذا
اللقاح على مدار الـ 12 شهرًا القادمة والتي
ستكون
استثنائية ورائعة تمامًا ،
ولكن إذا كان بإمكانك استخدام نظام نصف الجرعة ،
فستصبح ثلاثة مليارات بالتأكيد
تتوفر أربع مليارات ونصف المليار جرعة ،
لذلك هناك عدة
أسباب وراء رغبتك في استخدام
نظام الجرعات المنخفضة من الجرعات العالية.